this week we've got carry it on musk
find and screen blockers you all must
yeah oh what is a musk like last name
like what musk is like also a cologne
thing it's like scent right yeah it's
like a I took a waft of it's like a
thickness of an air it's a very loving
air all right our first story lax have
announced that they now have a new
marijuana policy where you can travel
through the airport with marijuana what
oh it goes through like you're allowed
to bring it on the plane or you can only
go through the airport well so they are
saying that now that it's legal in
California that lax Police Department
will allow passengers to travel through
lax with up to twenty eight point five
grams of marijuana and 8 grams of
concentrated marijuana that's all yeah
there's a huge but there's a big but
that's like that much weed you're
allowed to bring out the claimant yeah
but are you ready for the button so
federally you can still get arrested
that's what I'm saying oh yeah so why
would you be able to go on pay depending
on what you're trying all the days come
travel with us so the cops won't do
anything but the feds you're traveling
to Colorado it's cool yes so they are
saying that TSA could still prevent
people from boarding flights if they
find marijuana in the carry-on bags but
that the airport police will not
confiscate it help you so funny if you
get to Thailand you go straight to
prison saying that you need to read do
your research and see where it is that
you're flying to and if they allow that
Airport to also have the week that's too
much work by the time you get there
though they don't search you when you
get there surely soon as you were like
well it's great because if you register
with the State Department and then my
eyes glaze over yeah like I don't give a
[ __ ] if that's more than one
on my freakin drone in Morocco oh we get
there with the drone they don't check
our bags or anything but then we're
leaving the country and that's when they
take it away took your drone [ __ ]
drove away we didn't even use it in
Morocco lesson did you have a drone it
was the magic the memo yes the sick one
[ __ ] one that we have why do they take
it is our drones illegal there so
they're saying that you have to register
it with the department wait in their
particular department because I
registered it with our department no I
have to be in that in Morocco yeah and
then they were telling weeks I was so
fuming angry I never used it here fine
whatever you have your laws but we're
[ __ ] leaving yeah leave me why would
you take it you know what that's called
it because they can sell it it's called
the Moroccan birthday present yeah yeah
no amend exactly that's the first agent
dude he let us put the charger and the
propellers away in our carry-on like
you'd let us like they started yelling
at that dude like we need to have
everything I'm like why so you can sell
it you could keep it and then they told
us you know what if you go on this site
well you could put in your claim or
whatever and then we'll send it to you
whatever [ __ ] that obviously they're
never gonna say I don't know like hey do
you have any 32 gigabyte memory cuz like
this one's only 15 picture you could
have paid a mom we were trying to - what
did you say what did you say I'll give
you $100 we didn't say a price we're
just like listen cuz Casey was like we
need this for work cuz we were heading
to Croatia that's the reason why we took
it we didn't register it in Croatia and
they were like we're just like look we
really need it for our job like you're
affecting my work like yeah how much do
we need to pay to make you let us just
keep it I walk away and they're just
like no you can't buy us off and I'm
like what oh they said that to you my
child
really needs a birthday present alright
you cannot buy me off damn do you know
how long I've been waiting for this this
is a DJ it's cuz you went out in the
wrong way
Casey should have been like I'll show
you my but I will let you see my Casey
so home see he's very homey
that's why that's what they say do the
dogs can they smell marijuana can I
really can they smell drugs different
dogs are trained for different dudes can
smell cancer yeah they can
what tskalikan sniff out SD cards and
hard drives and yeah drug sniffing dogs
and then there's bomb dogs and all that
stuff oh that's how they define the
[ __ ] baby rapers right there how cuz
they submit make a smell behind hard
drives like the dogs will sniff them out
you think there's wear body in the dog
dogs can smell child porn in a hard
drive you're telling me a dog can smell
what a difference of a file is I'm outta
here like oh there's child porn in that
hear it smell like whatever a hard hard
delegate yeah they're they're trained to
sniff out like SD cards or whatever like
whatever they're trained to sniff out a
melon yeah shame all I know is they
enjoy smelling [ __ ] cuz that's how
they say what's up dude yeah like do
they get to know each other that way
they go
you think they can smell whether the dog
is a bomb dog or a drug dog like oh
you're a bomb dog the highest yeah of
the ranking my dog never astonished
[ __ ] ever really that's how they say
hi and then the way you know when they
pee that they send messages that way
yeah that's why they they go around and
go okay so this dog you know he doesn't
have iron and then you go this one this
one's kind of sad yeah it's it's like my
parents dog like that one who literally
doesn't give a [ __ ] about another dog
I've never seen a dog not care about
another dog in my life except for that
dog but literally it just dogs will come
up like what the [ __ ] just like go away
doesn't care about anybody else but
people that sounds like a cat yeah it's
weird dude if I was a drug dealer
I needed to move a [ __ ] big shipment
of drugs I would have the shipment of
drugs arrived at the same time as a big
shipment of just butt holes
Oh like a whole container filled with
[ __ ] cuz we don't care we kill
people and butcher em up and stuff you
just had you just carve out the butt
holes and you put them all in the big
container and the dogs will be all over
this [ __ ] and the drugs will move right
across the dogs will be conflicted they
like that's why they gotta train them so
they don't they don't act him you know
get distracted yeah whatever whatever
treats are using to train them that's
what you have to use oh I see do you
know you know it's animals [ __ ] up
though model animals those ones on the
dog food bags the cat food bags they're
[ __ ] up what happened dude I was on a
bag of cat food and I am so good with
cats I freaking love cats in order to
book that job I had a hold of cat in the
audition this cat was like a regular
human model it just looks right through
you it's like coked out like do you have
the drugs no do you have the drugs no
animal trader the Wrangler had to like
hold the spoon like on this side of my
head so the cat looks like it's looking
at me but it's really just looking at
drugs and it would get freaked out like
like you win a lot of make noises around
it because it would get super like
freaked out like with a book or you man
I need the drugs man you're [ __ ] up
it's like you can't pet them either
because it was a cat - didn't like no
yeah didn't like me weird cat and she's
like I had to because I don't wanted
drugs or something like yeah it's a cat
cats love me it's part of my identity
and I need to believe that that's true
you like cats over dogs right yeah but
you know I love dogs
it's just that I feel like this is a
stronger bond with a cat that you bet
you own like if it's if it's a random
cat not so much but like really but the
book yeah like they need to get to know
you that you build trust and then that
cow only loves you but this buckskin
yeah it's super loyal so it's not
something that people easily understand
it's like when you're doing stand-up and
you have to use conventional wisdom
you can't like introduce something that
people don't know unless you're cat
people
yeah cat people yeah yeah unless you
know your audience is captain
they had a cat that chose them I feel
like people that aren't cat people just
you just never had a cat that chose you
and that's sad
dogs do to the dogs mark one person for
the rest of their life
yeah so there's literally one if you
don't think there's a dog that will
clearly like one one owner over the
other so they'll literally choose one
person for the rest of their [ __ ]
life yeah [ __ ] disgust that's true
but they'll still come up and like be
friendly with other people right but
cats are usually like I don't know you
[ __ ] you really is just like like yeah
damn right he will come up to you he
only comes up to me I had to feel bad
trust my my brother was you know my cats
are really friendly like they're almost
like dog yeah yeah your cats are
friendly I'm [ __ ] allergic you [ __ ]
kills me every time here than the other
one she's too shy I have a cat one
another cats he is he might see him
friendly but really he's just
investigating you hosts everybody he's
like make sure that you're not a bad guy
my brother was house-sitting for this
for this friend and this this this cat
was so creepy like a dog like do you
would just walk up and he's going his
belly like oh it's so [ __ ] weird I
was like I've never seen a cat that's
that shy one that she doesn't go up to
you guys but every time Casey's doing
push up she has to be right underneath
the show she always screws me up I can
never do mice that's right yeah I'm sure
that's a reason why they get so confused
but dude any time I'm doing push-ups
they're the same [ __ ] they crawl under
you for summer I don't know why are you
there like what are you doing
especially me you're like you never do
this come on do like this thing where
she's like playing Oh
they think you're playing so for our
next story
whether that whole last segment was just
meaning and all of my aunts and uncles
everyone's telling cats and dogs I'm
looking at my watch I know I know
thank you I like it I secretly like it
it's seen a lot March of all did
yesterday it's like nobody [ __ ] cares
yeah oh my next story Elon Musk will
have to pay twenty million dollars to
the SCC
and resign as chair of twice what is the
marijuana thing for a tweet because of
this tweets doing some shell tweet
though we've already talked about back
in August the one that said I'm
considering taking Tesla private at 420
funding secured what so because I tweets
he has now been fined twenty million he
has to step down his chair why
Securities and Exchange Commission could
you're misleading shareholders he was
misleading and false amore but that's
troll and though he's joking but this
stuff it affected the [ __ ] I feel like
anything on Twitter should be valued as
entertainment only yeah she didn't be
like a for an official statement good
look at her president but isn't it but
isn't it um isn't it their fault if
people don't get the joke well or can
you you get in trouble for joking well
because it affected the market like it
influenced the market but that's but
it's a joke well you can't make a joke
now was that a joke yeah it's 4/20 yeah
oh it's a marijuana nice that's pretty
good actually I guess I don't know
that's [ __ ] yeah and then Tesla also
got fined twenty million dollars we're
not keeping an eye on his social media
stuff what happened did you don't have
some money hey you know what's so crazy
about that Seamus right they don't even
do that for the President of the United
States well hit him I don't know if he's
joking or not and so it's hard to tell
right but then in this case it's a clear
[ __ ] it's clearly a joke I think it's
it's what we're seeing right now is a
battle of like culture and communication
like we have the older generation that
don't [ __ ] get it some of them do but
then we have ours that enjoy it mm-hmm
and then it's like button heads that's
what we did one is more legit how
I don't tweet because you would they can
hold any tweets against dudn't off for
the rest of your life you know sighs
don't [ __ ] do it
I think that people that take me that
serious is [ __ ] stupid
yeah they'll take anything out of
context but everyone takes everything so
serious yeah go through my old tweets
see if the Internet is of a source of
rage they're just like looking for
something I think I think you can't be
someone like neilando and be
trollee and funny like if he was that in
the very beginning since PayPal days and
they knew that this guy was a [ __ ]
goof then I think you'll be okay but
it's twitter twitter what is saying
twitter should not be an official source
of information but I get it though
because it's it's like I guess it
started [ __ ] with people's money so
then there has to be some type of
accountability but that's just people
being better because they're stupid and
didn't like over something yeah I agree
man I don't know what it's like to lose
20 million and be like I know most of us
will never make that in a lifetime like
we'd have to reincarnate 10 times to
[ __ ] make that one and then inflation
is like let us have you reincarnate to
make that life is not even worth that
much that's for sure
that's like god that's like a hamburger
and so he's but he's not leaving Tesla
right no still a/c because that company
is how CEO he's not gonna be a chairman
over a bit man careers that's so stupid
I think it's like business laws
conflicting with like regular human
being common sense and then it's like
but it's totally affecting them the
stock market though because yeah it was
down 14% and then went up 17% like after
they found out that's crazy from a tweet
what happens when people report like
like shitty like we see economic news
all the time get corrected later like
it's the same [ __ ] yeah what's the
difference I don't know I'm not in my
mind
yeah you BOTS because he is famous and
they want to make an example yeah I
think so yeah but yeah I mean I always
wondered to the whole thing with the
election and how they did find out
somehow that the Russian
interfere like weeps and how does that
still make Trump valid well they said it
never it didn't impact the results of
the election but then they did say that
Facebook impacted the results right I
don't know they said that there were ads
box yeah their ads bought I kind of like
half-assed pay attention to politics and
like oh that's like a whole other thing
I mean the same thing happened during
the Bush administration they say that he
stole the election because later they
found out that you're able to manipulate
the results of the the technology of
those the default machines sad things
election machines were it was like a
deed they were done by Diebold or some
[ __ ] I remember that conspiracy was
pretty interesting yeah it was like no
matter what people voted the gatekeepers
could change the results or giving that
statistic to like the official or the
news sources or whatever and then so but
that that's kind of long and gone and
everyone forgot about that but the
amount of money that you're talking
about that was spent on Facebook ads is
like two million dollars I'm sure it was
like yeah but when you think about an
election each side and spending a
billion each it's like I don't know
that's a lot of money all right for our
last story there are these glasses on
Kickstarter right now that they're
called IRL glasses or in real life oh I
got it young good job team thank you
that's right and so these glasses is
what it looks like it just look like
regular glasses they do just they do
something they look like NWA 1998
gangster oh yeah true in 82 games that's
what they actually do we block out
screens what I'm like when the users
wearing it they'll block outs look at
that yeah that's sick so like if you're
just tired of seeing a whole bunch of
screens all over that's cool
he's on and it's kind of like like
checking out sort of yeah like blocking
out all the wonder if that [ __ ] with
your mind and eyes well there's and it's
like this this like certain screen
like the like that thing yeah yes like
this actually I think you might imagine
is being at work and you're just wearing
these glasses on your laptop or didn't
do work hey guys eight hours of doing
that and they're like why are you
wearing glasses inside [ __ ]
they are things you already said I'm an
[ __ ] yeah so these work with most TVs
so it works with LCD and LED and some
computers that are LCD and LED they
don't work on Oh LED hmm and they don't
work on cell phones either the new
iPhones yeah and then they don't work
like if you tilt your head or you turn
your head somehow it doesn't work you oh
that's like that yeah yeah so it is like
you guys miss pretending to work
I miss pretend more pretending to work
it was fun I got the office and [ __ ]
like most people could get their job
done before lunch
yeah and like you're already done and
then but then you got to now stretch out
like whatever so you open up an email
and you spend like one hour just reading
that one paragraph kind of type it no
and then you get up and you print some
[ __ ] out and you got it still look busy
you know I feel like I do that now to my
own self
like I'm like no worky I'm editing this
video because before I was a waitress
you can't pretend to waitress you like
you have to serve your table but like
now what about when it gets slow though
when it gets slow you got to like find
something to do so you milk out some go
to the bathroom that's out yeah that's
outside corporate life is though where
you can't wait to go to the water cooler
and refill your yeah so you could talk
to someone there just for something some
kind of human interaction Alya I love
pooping at work I mean I'm the only one
here who has like a nine-to-five right I
think so I think so wait your jobs in
nine-to-five yeah I go to work at 9:00
leave it are you cheating work right now
I am at work right now yeah this is work
right
I'm pretending to work right now you
work at BuzzFeed right yes yeah yeah so
anyway I love pooping because thank you
for what you do and we're sleeping with
the enemy you sugar seein as you saying
I love pooping yeah well it's at least
uh you know what they used to be nicer
we're gonna start up life because we
would get those our own cubicle bathroom
and now it's like the corporate bathroom
because we've got bigger three years the
video team was a lot smaller back then
but three years is like ancient and
digital channel ah yeah I remember I
used to though I would I want to show up
to work earlier than my boss and then
leave later so sometimes I would like
but those early and late they're just
pooping stretch out the time you poop
when everybody's there ah they know that
your alleys have work and then you
pretend like you're working in the
morning before your boss gets there it
looks good yeah when your pockets are
you then you go to the bathroom
oh hey good morning I'm sending this to
your boss every day until something is
done well you know it's like I have no
shame don't you do a Food Channel - yeah
yeah that burritos you're taking some
interesting dumps cuz you need different
things you know we talk about our dumps
yes Oh actually that's work yeah that's
true your research and stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]